el magistrado John Roberts y la mayoría
conservadora de la Corte Suprema de
Justicia que tiene seis de las nueve
sillas Indicó que la administración de
Joe biden violó la separación de poderes
al querer con donar cuatrocientos mil
millones de dólares de deuda estudiantil
sin la autorización del Congreso
comentario que es un revés para la
administración de Joe biden y su interés
de aliviar la deuda de más de 40
millones de estadounidenses por su parte
Elena cagan magistrada de corte liberal
argumentó que la administración de biden
actuó en respuesta de la pandemia y las
necesidades de los estadounidenses de
hecho tras la pandemia y la crisis
inflacionaria que vive el país 53% de
los prestatarios dice que la estabilidad
financiera de ellos depende del alivio
de la deuda el plan anunciado
inicialmente en agosto del 2022
cancelaría Diez mil dólares de deuda de
los préstamos estudiantiles federales
aquellos que ganan menos de 125 mil
dólares al año y hay que Resaltar que
esta deuda estudiantil asciende a uno
punto siete billones de dólares la
segunda más grande después de la deuda
hipotecaria también hay que mencionar
que la decisión final el fallo final de
la Corte Suprema de Justicia se conocerá
en junio de este año